are hearing reports of new attacks
across ukraine including in the capital
city at this hour we'll of course be
monitoring those
until you when we learn more
but first on last night's show we try to
bring you as straightforward an analysis
as we could of the invasion of ukraine
it was then in progress it still is the
war at that point was less than 24 hours
old and it seemed disrespectful and
wrong
to use the deaths of people on the
ground as a partisan cudgel
war is horrifying of course but it's
also a grave and profound thing you
ought to stand back and offer a moment
before you start drawing convenient
conclusions from the suffering you see
death is a mystery acknowledge that
that's how we feel joe biden's allies
the medias do not feel that way they use
the opportunity to attack their
political opponents immediately as they
always do they have no restraint and no
shame we're grateful not to be them
so that was last night tonight it's fair
to note the obvious the invasion of
ukraine
is a humiliating defeat for joe biden
he's our leader he staked this country's
reputation billions of dollars and the
full force of the us government on
preventing vladimir putin from invading
ukraine vladimir putin invaded ukraine
anyway
and america is diminished by that
it's not the first time joe biden has
done something like this less than six
months ago biden oversaw an almost
indescribably chaotic withdrawal from
afghanistan he left american citizens
behind he armed the taliban with
advanced weapon systems on the way out
it could not have been worse
so here you have two historic foreign
policy debacles in under a year
is there a precedent for that
what's the message of it well weakness
obviously republicans often say that but
as usual don't go far enough weakness
well north korea is weak
they literally have famines people
starve to death in north korea that's
weakness
but there's still a nation we have to
contend with because they bite
a venomous spider is weak you can crush
it but you're still afraid of it
because it bites
we do not bite
and that's the problem
we're not simply weak the united states
government under joe biden is ridiculous
it's pompous it's self-involved it's
long-winded and fatuous it's not so
different from the fading old man who
leads it
there's no hiding this the rest of the
world sees it clearly so do many
americans
if watching the invasion of ukraine this
week made you feel a little sick this is
probably why
of course you felt sorry for the
ukrainians being killed
but you also sense that this was a
genuine disaster for us in america and
you're right it is
joe biden is quickly draining the
reservoir of america's credibility and
power that has accumulated over
centuries of wise decision-making like
the us treasury this is not joe biden's
capital to spend he is squandering
something that others made how much is
left at this point i hate even to think
about it someday we're going to find out
so the problem here isn't complicated
joe biden broke the oldest rule of vault
don't make threats you can't back up
you'd think he'd know that if he'd
actually squared off against corn pop at
the public swimming pool in wilmington
60 years ago
but he never did so he doesn't know that
if you say something serious you had
better mean it it is reckless to tell
obvious lies
if you do that before long and it
happens very quickly in fact people
figure out that you can be ignored
you're not a superpower you're a joke
and that's why you never under any
circumstances say anything like this
the purpose of the sanctions has always
been and continues to be deterrence
but let's also recognize
the unique nature of the sanctions that
we have outlined
these are some of the greatest sanctions
if not the the strongest that we've ever
issued the president believes that
sanctions are intended to deter as to
the sanctions the most important thing
we can do is to use them as a deterrent
as a means of dissuading russia from
engaging in further aggression
now if you saw the dates you noticed
those clips are from recently in some
cases just days before vladimir putin
showed precisely how meaningless our
sanctions actually were the greatest
sanctions ever said kamala harris
wearing her stupid little mask on monday
she's a buffoon
you knew that
now it's obvious that her buffoonery is
a real peril for the rest of us
no one in the white house seems to
understand this it's life's most obvious
lesson
so here was joe biden from today telling
you that actually these sanctions the
greatest most deterrent sanctions ever
were never intended really to deter
anything sorry if it took us seriously
the first time we didn't really mean it
no one expected the sanctions to prevent
anything from happening
it has to show this is going to take
time
and we have to show resolve so he knows
what's coming and so the people of
russia know what he's brought on them
that's what this is all about
who gives him these scripts do they not
think we have access to youtube or maybe
they're just hoping google will scrub it
by the time he holds another press
conference you just told us on monday
that the purpose of these sanctions was
to deter the invasion of ukraine so at
the very least acknowledge they didn't
work as intended
they can never acknowledge that oh the
vaccine prevents transmission and
infection
just tell the truth people will
understand but they lie every time
now they're telling us putin knows
what's coming we'll get him next time
right no one believes you anymore joe
biden no one should believe you it is
very hard to take unserious people
seriously a serious president who cared
would have reassessed everything
america's foreign policy and how it's
administered after the afghanistan
withdrawal last august that was a
disaster
so a responsible person would have asked
himself how do we prevent this from
happening again that's how responsible
people think it's how leaders who care
about their countries think of course
it's the baseline requirement for
leadership
this was a disaster how do we prevent it
from happening again that's not hard
but lifetime federal employee that he is
joe biden did the opposite of that his
first instinct was to protect the
bureaucracy not the country the
bureaucracy so not a single person from
the pentagon or the state department was
fired or even reprimanded in fact
famously the only person who was
punished in the end for that historic
debacle was a marine colonel who
complained about it he went to jail for
complaining
and you will see the same response this
time
after the disastrous invasion of ukraine
the american officials who so publicly
trashed this country's credibility will
be promoted for it they always are
toriya newland is one of the geniuses
behind the iraq war that was almost 20
years ago did that hurt her career it
should have should have ended her career
in place right then go do something
useful
learn how to lay tile
but it didn't enter a career in fact
your career accelerated in fact this
same person tori newland went on to help
lead the ukraine debacle we're watching
now
she's completely unqualified for the job
she has we knew that 20 years ago
and yet she's highly successful in
washington someday she'll probably be
the secretary of state remember her name
tori newland
she'll be rewarded for failing
meanwhile people who criticize troy
newland or who care enough about this
country to critique joe biden's foreign
policy disasters find themselves
denouncing the media as of all things
traitors to america
and then spied on by the nsa
you see how that works it's all
self-protection
and because it is only buffoonery is
rewarded
and that's exactly why john kerry is
still around here's john kerry telling
the bbc in public on camera that the
real victim of this war is something
called the climate
massive
uh emissions consequences to the war but
equally importantly you're going to lose
people's focus you're going to lose
certainly big country attention because
they will be diverted and and i think it
could have a damaging impact so i hope
president putin will help us to stay on
track with respect to what we need to do
for the climate
and of course he he flew private to that
interview hoping nobody noticed not
caring if anyone noticed like what's the
explanation behind how could you say
something like that that clip is real we
didn't make it up it's hard to believe
it but it is real it's all real
if you did a nationwide search for the
people least capable of leading a large
nation through complicated times you
would get our leadership class you would
get john kerry oh we found him
the search is over
and of course at the very top of that
list would be john kerry's friend
hillary clinton
so here's hillary clinton revealing the
real story
she's telling you that the actual enemy
in this war is not in russia not eastern
ukraine it's not vladimir putin
it's you
the real enemy of this country is anyone
who dares to criticize the mismanagement
of hillary clinton and her friends watch
i think it's time for
what's left of the uh
republican party that has any common
sense not just to say okay go help
defend ukraine against uh putin but to
stand against those people in politics
and government in the media and
elsewhere in our own country who are
literally giving aid and comfort to an
enemy of freedom and democracy
it can't it can't continue because it
plays right into the ambitions of not
just putin but also president xi of
china to undermine democracy to
literally
divide and conquer the west without ever
invading us but by setting us against
each other
your opinions are the real threat to
democracy
dare criticize us and we will denounce
you as a dangerous traitor
because that's democracy
so vladimir putin invades ukraine but
guess whose fault it is
it's your fault
notice the theme here it's always your
fault
every single time
and they're going to punish you for it
hillary did say one interesting thing in
that clip probably inadvertently
she'd say it but the illusion was there
russia and china are now aligned as a
block against the united states now
how'd that happen it's pretty obvious
you're looking around the world you're
thinking who are the big powers with
meaningful economies and nuclear weapons
maybe they shouldn't be aligned against
us that's just the simplest kind of math
maybe we shouldn't do anything that
pushes our enemies into a block
because that threatens us
but they don't know that that's
happening or maybe they're in favor of
it god knows what the bidet
administration is thinking according to
the new york times quote the united
states met with china over three months
to present intelligence showing russia's
troop buildup near ukraine and to urge
beijing to help avert war
chinese officials
rebuffed to the united states and then
shared that information
with moscow
oh
yeah
so we went to china for help to prevent
putin from invading ukraine at the very
moment that russia and china were
forming a very public alliance against
us
did that really happen apparently it
really did happen
how long can this go on and maybe that's
why biden didn't mention china during
his press conference
he gave them our intelligence and they
gave it to putin
perfect but don't mention that or you're
a traitor
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else